everybody to gary vay-ner-chuk and this
is Gary Vaynerchuk calm or I like to do
business videos and I'm going to do a
lot more of them and one of the ways I'm
going to be using this platform going
forward by the way so sorry about the
last post to friend up from down I
totally agree not enough content let me
rethink that idea but what I want to be
using this format for is also maybe kind
of looking inside myself and figure out
what I'll be doing that is helping me be
successful or hurting me so it's fun to
hang of this community I miss you guys
I'm going to leave what today's video is
about it's about something I've been
doing my whole life and I only dawned on
me really this week while there was home
at the be nurture compound visit my
parents with my brother AJ and sister
Liz her husband Justin my nephew little
max Misha Lizzy the parents AJ is
wonderful girlfriend had a great time at
mazing we comes off the grid
spending time so I wasn't tweeting or
doing a whole lot of things and
something happened along the way EJ and
I because we have a parents attic they
were looking at all this stuff
some of you know for my keynotes that AJ
and I used to go out and eBay right you
see when AJ was 12 13 14 15 16 I wanted
to teach him the hustle buying and
selling teaching the negotiate and spend
time with him and nothing was better
nothing was better than those Saturday
mornings waking him at 5:00 a.m.
while I was still running Wine Library
and putting in a lot of retail hours
waking up at 5:00 am meeting a jam to
store at 6:00 going to flea markets
garage of buying stuff and then selling
them on eBay there was tremendous
bonding which then eight hours the car
together and we recreated it this last
Saturday so we went out we just in the
name Jay got about 6 a.m. one of the
last things I can actually sleep but no
no sleep till Brooklyn
decided all this time to Somerset New
Jersey we got up early went the
Bridgewater Somerset we ran around
we bought some stuff Commodore 64 some
old clothes all this stuff that we knew
we had a blast hanging out negotiating
fun stories those systemd what 16 will
give you 10 all this fun stuff that's
something happened that I bought this
and I think anybody who knows me knows I
want to buy the jet so I hate the Dallas
Cowboys but I know that no classes
the morning of the Cowboys you collect
one as you can see it's old-school I
bought this thing for 50 cents I posted
it on eBay for a 58 99 by an out of 1222
minimum bid I got a bit about an hour to
it and then something happened and
that's what's leading this video the
excitement in my body when I got that
big 12 22 in comparison to when I got a
formal offer for speaking gig in April
from CA my management team unspeaking
that's paying $40,000 the difference in
my body from that $40,000 speaking gig
and this 12 22 bid on this cup was
substantial there was so much more
excitement and so much more happiness
about this bid over that that I was
incredible I really asked myself what is
that yeah in my junk stir what what is
giving me that high why do I want to
right now not work and go to like all
the thrift stores in New York and go to
storage wars and bid on stuff and spend
all day and make 180 bucks and
comparison to all these opportunities
and I realized ever so often every so
often excuse me through my career and
mine has been eBay it's been my business
vacation I think people have to start
thinking about what I call the SBB the
simple business vacation I believe that
a lot of people who are doing well or
maybe nothing been doing social well but
I definitely see a lot of people who are
doing quite well worried about lowering
themselves and doing something silly
that doesn't scale or bring the most
money to the table I always felt that
what this does is gives me a mental
vacation sure you can take the vacation
with the family which is what I've been
doing quite a bit in the last couple
weeks sure you can go out a beach solar
sure you can do things but if you love
the game if you love the hustle if you
want business as much as I do if
business is your passion as a hobby this
is my honey my father used to go and buy
stuff than any sell it I love it that
much it's that much in my DNA I think
that too many people are scared to do
small business vacations simple business
vacations that they're scared that their
fortune 500 CEO that they can't just on
they that they can't open up a car wash
and have somebody run it for them
well what on a simpler means even if
you're $100,000 a year earner that you
can't go and garage sale on eBay or
start a t-shirt business things that
would dive in your brand lower than
where you are I find it very fascinating
if a lot of discussions about this I
think that people that are really
hustling and really really looking to
build something if they have an enormous
passion for business there's a lot of
things out there that you can use
fishing and sailing and exercising tons
I get but what happens when business is
your vacation what happens when business
is your outlet are you willing to
position yourself in a place where you
might be embarrassed listen making this
video right now is not so easy when I
tweet it out people like I can't see you
doing that going out and buying other
people's trash and stop buying it for 50
cents and selling it for 12 bucks
doesn't seem so profound doesn't seem
like you're gonna buy the Jets doing
that but it makes me happy it just does
and I wonder if there's a lot of other
people out there that are having those
same concerns not willing to do
something because it seems silly below
them you know maybe you've got a 100
million dollar round or you've got a fun
you're blowing up and you're getting
written about all day what you really
want to do on the side is open a bake
shop and sell some damn cookies sell
those damn cookies